so in a previous life I worked at a
software company that built software for
caseworkers in child welfare so I was on
their data science team and I don't
remember what exactly my team was doing
at the time but I do remember and that
we were looking in the data and we were
seeing had like a bunch of children in
our database that were older than their
parents and not only were they older
than their parents they were like a lot
older than their parents and they were
like a lot older than everyone and so
when we actually looked at the birth
dates you know we sort of plotted them
visually we started poking around in the
database it was really easy to see what
had happened which was that there was a
bug in our application such that when a
caseworker entered a child's birth date
if they entered the year with just two
digits instead of four we would not you
know prepend the century information on
the front and so everyone that works
with data has stories like this you
expect the data to behave a certain way
you're sort of carrying around that
latent assumption in your head and that
assumption actually turns out not to
hold so my name is Jane fast-forward a
couple of years and I now work at two
Sigma investments I work with very
different kinds of data and I'm doing
very different kinds of things with data
now but I'm still spending a lot of time
thinking about this problem which is
that we make so many assumptions about
data and we're really really bad at
validating those assumptions so what
were my assumptions in this in this
little story I mean the first one pretty
basic children are born after their
parents and the second one is that you
know people can't live forever there's
an upper bound to how old a person
should be you know so if I'm looking at
a children that's born in the year 8
like not only am i concerned that they
were born before their parent I'm also
concerned that they're like really
really freaking old so of course like
these aren't the only things you know
that I assume about data so what are the
other
one of the other things we generally
assume um my assumption about the birth
dates is getting at one of the most you
know central ones which is that we
assume that the the values in our data
set are correct right they correspond to
actual values in the actual world
another one that's pretty common is that
we assume that we're not missing any
data I think probably everyone in this
room that works with data knows that
that assumption gets violated all the
time another one might be that we assume
that records are unique and the reason
that this assumption is important is
that you know if you have duplicates in
your database that can interfere with
things like headcount which messes with
budgeting which messes with staffing
like there's all sorts of problems that
can come if you get your headcount wrong
and then finally this sort of doesn't
apply I don't think I really ever
carried this assumption around when I
was working with child welfare data but
let's say you have data coming from a
sensor you might assume that that
sensors measurements are precise and so
what that means is that if you take
multiple readings from that sensor the
measurements are been gonna be pretty
close they're gonna be clustered around
each other and of course this is a non
exhaustive list we assume a lot more
things about data once you actually
start thinking about it I'm sure you can
come up with many and so what you really
why am I talking about this why does
this matter why does it matter that we
have all these assumptions about data
and the reason it matters is that we
don't just have data to have it we use
data to make decisions and some of those
decisions are life critical so a child's
age is an important factor to consider
when you're looking at emergency
placement options for a child and the
emergency placement options that you
might consider for an infant are totally
different than the ones that you would
consider for a teenager and so the
upshot of that is you know in child
welfare for example when time is of the
essence
we want caseworkers to have the right
information at their fingertips right so
this is why this this is why this
matters
no more and the broader theme is that
you know we owe it to ourselves to be
explicit about our assumptions and that
should include our assumptions about the
data that we use to drive our decisions
so what are the important problems here
right so I'm like okay I'm on board I'm
like right I'm like motivated it's
really important for me to be explicit
about my assumptions you know where do I
you know how do I sort of come up with
my assumptions so we're usually doing
that when we first get a dataset we're
in our initial analysis phase this is
when we're spending the most time with a
dataset we're exploring it we're trying
to figure out what we want to do with it
we're learning its quirks were maybe
changing it in various ways and we learn
a whole bunch about it we you know write
some models we write some applications
like who knows what we do with it and
then we don't really look at it again
you know we built up all those
assumptions we got our data working for
whatever we wanted to do and then we
moved on to the next thing and rarely do
we write those assumptions down so the
reason that that's a problem is that
data are always changing so a really
common way that data change are that you
simply get more data but I think we've
all probably encountered data schemas
change another interesting way that data
can change are if that sort of panel
that the data are coming from you know
it changes and grows over time your
sensor might get upgraded it might get
replaced with a completely different
sensor or you know your data offender
might expand to like a new geography of
the world so all of a sudden you've got
like a new country and that's sort of
contributing data to your dataset
related to this problem is that some of
these changes are going to be really
loud they're gonna break your ETL
processes they're gonna break your
scripts they're gonna tell you like hey
like I am data I have changed your stuff
doesn't work anymore those are really
friendly and like really polite failures
because they announced themselves there
are gonna be other failures that are
just going to totally slip by you you're
never gonna see them coming a really
common one is if you have a categorical
variable and levels of the domain of
that variable get added or dropped
that's a really really hard thing to
catch it's not allowed failure and
one is just that your data never arrived
so we're like data always changing we
have all these assumptions about data
we're not good about you know writing
them down and validating them validating
them and part of that is that like many
knowing checking data is like difficult
it's inconsistent in its error-prone
like you have to remember to do it you
have to remember how to do it and that's
hard enough with just one data set but
like imagine you're working with tens of
data sets or hundreds or thousands of
data sets and imagine that not only are
you working with thousands of different
data sets all of those different they're
like completely different kinds of data
and so you're constantly trying to
contact switch between what are my
important assumptions about all of these
data that I'm trying to work with right
now so hello i'm leaf I work with Jane
I'm not a data person I'm a software
person and so Jane and I were talking
about this and we started thinking maybe
we want to try to build something to
solve this problem and so we started
writing down what are the things that we
actually need to get done to help deal
with the fact that these people are
gonna change and might no longer our
assumptions may no longer hold in the
future and we want to sort of know about
that so we want to take our assumptions
and write them down in a way that we can
evaluate them automatically we don't
want to have to like writing down just
the words you know we don't expect
children to be older than their parents
is not enough like we could give that to
a person and they could recheck the data
every day but we want a computer do this
to do this for us
and to do it in the same way every time
and then the rest of it kind of falls
out we want to take the thing the
specification that we wrote and run it
every time we import new data or update
old data we want to get a report when
something that we thought was true is no
longer true
and this is a minor point but we want to
report everything that all of the
assumptions that didn't hold not just
like the first one so you can imagine
putting this into like a data ingestion
pipeline you don't want to just stop at
the first one you want to see everything
that was going on that was weird so that
you can go do something about it and so
what we asked was can we write like unit
tests for data because I'm a software
person and I like testing like code can
I test my data so we pulled out unit
tests and kind of started playing with
it wrote some tests and started
evaluating like does this work and it
pretty much does
so each test method can be can like load
in some data and then compute some fact
about it like how old are all these
people in our database and it can say
they should probably be less than 150
years old we can we can write that and
have a computer executed and then we can
kind of just put this into whatever
process is ingesting data we can put it
into a cron job we can put it in front
of our ingestion scripts and/or sort of
after cleaning phase of proof data
ingestion we can take these things and
run them wherever we we need and unit
tests like we'll run all of our tests
and we'll give us a whole report of
which failures happened and so this
actually like this works pretty well and
you can pick sort of any unit test or
you can figured any testing tool and
mostly like the feature that you're
using is the test execution thing
everything else is just the code the
code that you wrote we you know test
because we work at a company with a lot
of developers and j-unit is like
familiar to them and so unit test kind
of looks similar but like you could pick
any of them so at this point like we
want to kind of show you how this works
but we can't show you
child welfare do you know
we also don't have it and we also can't
show you any of two Sigma's data so
we're gonna take this public data set
there's a bunch of bike share programs
in different cities like New York has
city bike Boston has a bike share
program called a hub way that when I was
practicing or building up this talk
found out that they changed their name
to blue bikes in 2015
surprise and if you go to their go to
their website there's like a this is
actually a link it goes to someplace in
s3 you can download a bunch of zip files
full of CSVs and this is like the schema
from one of the records so let's look at
what's in here and then try and talk
about what some assumptions might be so
we've got start time and stop time and
how long the difference of those two
numbers is we've got information about
how like where the trip started and
ended we've got some latitude and
longitude and those might be fun we've
got some kind of internal Mike ID I
don't know what this would be but
presumably maybe they're unique and I've
got information about the person who
took the trip
I've actually got their birth year so we
could do age stuff if we want
and apparently gender is 0 1 or 2 I
don't know what those mean but so like
what's that I mean there's way more than
three genders so who wants to like come
up with something what what might we
assume about a dataset like this that's
a good one
anyone else use your hands should be on
the earth somewhere that's a really good
one no sorry should definitely be near
Boston that's a good one
okay okay so obviously
trip time yeah you can't but yeah yeah
so the trip time was a really cool one
should be not yes correct so there were
no negative trips in the data that I
looked at
there were trips that lasted like over a
month I'm guessing someone just like
left the bike somewhere and someone came
along and found it and plugged it back
in later but like those are the kinds of
things that you find if you start
looking for for failures of these things
but of course so we want to show you how
to have tested a site like this and we
had to write the stuff beforehand
because we don't type as fast as James
Powell so here's the one that we chose
we want to check to make sure that trips
are not like really far because we get
start and end points but we don't get
like total distance traveled like the
wheel doesn't have an odometer on it but
we can do like point-to-point distance
and so we know all the stations are in
Boston so we know like they should be
less than the diameter of Boston for
some definition of Boston so how do you
write a test for this first you have
some kind of setup that we're emitting
here it's just like open up a zip file
pandas read CSV whatever hidden in that
ellipses yes an ellipsis hidden in that
ellipsis is we're also computing the
distance so like given two lat/long
points there's a formula if anyone wants
to look it up you can and you can find
like the distance and I'm computing it
in meters here and then the next thing
you do is you want to write a test
method that says what your assumption is
and checks for it and so first we're
setting up some thresholds and just to
add a little bit a flavor
I didn't look
how wide Boston is but a marathon and
like the distance of Marathon is a
little bit over 42 kilometers and so we
might say if someone bikes that far like
that's pretty crazy but also like even
if someone just bikes a 10k that's
that's pretty interesting I kind of want
to see something about that too and so
for each of these thresholds we're gonna
check more than any trips longer than
that
and so here if you're not familiar with
pandas it's pretty simple we're taking
the data that we read up in the setup
script or the set up function and we're
finding the subset of it where the
distance traveled is larger than this
threshold value and so long trips will
be a new data set that is just that
subsample and then we just assert that
the number of trips that were that long
is empty so what does this give us it
fails so cool so we the the thing did
what we expected it to which was to
detect when there were trips that
violated the assumption that they're not
very very long so so as we mentioned
before we can take this test that we
broke we can schedule it in a cron and
our question might be okay like what is
this give us now so the first thing is
that all our new data are automatically
tested for long trips where long trips
is longer than a 10k or a marathon we
don't have to remember how to test for
long trips right we wrote it down and
it's executable and another thing that's
pretty interesting is that we can easily
run this test on on historical data so
not just um sort of data on the future
it's very easy to take a test method
like this and run it over all the data
you've accumulated up to this point and
so what we can do is we can take all of
the other assumptions that everyone in
this room came up with and we can write
test methods for all of those as well
and we're in a pretty good spot at that
point right you know we've thought
through our assumptions about the data
we've made them explicit by writing them
down and we've made them executable
writing them inside test methods we've
automated them and I think we got a gold
star so cool set all these things up
Iran and nothing fails for a while until
we get this failure again and because
this is months away and we filled in the
rest of the owl we wrote all the other
tests
Jane sees this and can't remember what
false is not true means or why I care
about long trips so she asks is there a
way to see local variables in my unit
test output and I said I think PI test
does that which is a really funny story
if you go read the marbled stalks later
so I originally asked is there a way for
me to see local variables in my test
output but the more I thought about it
the more I realized that there was
actually a lot of information that I was
missing and it wasn't just the local
variables that I was missing so I'm
looking at this test failure and some of
the questions that come to mind for me
are like what is this test doing and
like why is it here another really
important thing is like what am I
supposed to do about it's like okay you
found long trips like and you know do I
delete those long trips do i redownload
the data another thing that I don't that
I can't really tell is like how bad is
it
like it was the trip you know one meter
over a marathon or was it like orders of
magnitude did someone bike like several
marathons
I can't tell and also you know people
that work with data this is probably
gonna be a pretty familiar one to you is
you're like okay have I seen this kind
of behavior before have I seen this
shape of problem before and like when
because that past experience is going to
inform what I'm doing right now and the
grand theme here is that this context is
really expensive to recover so I knew
all of these things when I wrote that
test
and yet when months go by and this test
starts failing that failure message
doesn't show me
any of that information and so this
problem of you know that like context is
expensive to recover this isn't unique
to data like we also have a problem you
know with software unit tests like it
can also be hard looking at a test
you're like what the hell is this doing
I completely forget what this was doing
it I write this thing but it's
especially hard with data and it's
especially hard with data for a couple
of reasons and the first is that our
assumptions about data aren't often a
clear-cut black-and-white yes or no but
in order to encode it into a test we
have to translate our assumption about
the data into sort of like a binary
pass/fail that can be evaluated and we
do lose when we make that translation
from our sort of vague expectation about
the data into a binary pass/fail we lose
some information about what we were
thinking the second is that failures and
data are usually introduced by someone
else so this is different than software
unit test failures so a really common
way that software unit test failures
start failing is like you're working on
a code base you're making changes to the
code you're running the tests and all of
a sudden something breaks but you are
you know you're in there like mucking
around in the code so you probably have
a really good idea of what change to
sort of cause the failure that you're
seeing right now but we don't muck with
data like that you know we don't
hopefully hopefully we're not doing that
we really don't mess with data like that
often often data failures are introduced
you know by some sort of upstream some
process upstream of you some sort of
ingestion transformation process it
might even be outside of your
organization it might be something that
your data vendor is doing and what this
means is that you probably have little
to no insight not only into what changed
about the data but who did it and why
and finally this is another thing that
sort of distinguishes distinguishes data
unit tests from software unit tests is
that the follow-up is different so when
a test starts failing it's pretty
natural for your you know for your first
thing to be like okay how do I get this
thing passing again
so I could get my test passing by just
removing the long trips but like we
can't just go around destroying data
look you can't really you can't really
do that and so the follow-up might be
that I need to go talk to you know it
might be that I need to like pop open
the data set and like you know look at
these lat/longs and like look at this
particular try to find the trips that
are really long and see sort of what's
happening and it might be that I need to
go talk to the data vendor or whatever
and you know that follow up pretty
straightforward but again imagining you
know I have like thousands of these
tests and each of them might have a
different sort of follow-up
for one of them I might need to pop open
the data for another one of them I might
need to call the vendor and yell at them
it could be totally different and I'm
trying and how am I gonna you know keep
track of all of that information and so
I found I like actually found myself in
this situation I actually found myself
having this problem and I you know I
looked at leaf and I was like you know
is there a way you know I knew all of
this stuff when I wrote this test is
there any way that I could recover it
all in the failure message and so we
wrote a thing so essentially it's a we
wrote a thing which is an extension of
you know tests that does some subtle
things to allow you to carry this
context forward and there's a way that
you use it and we'll get to that but
what I want to show first is what you
get at the end so what does the message
that you get look like and how is it
different from what you normally get out
of unit test some of these things are
gonna be familiar if you've used other
test vendors I think some are for some
are not so this is what a failure looks
like in marbles this is running the same
test that we saw before all right and
there's a couple things that you'll see
and the first question that we were
asking about the old failure message was
what is this test doing and so marbles
will give you those local variables that
we talked about that
I test does in a slightly different way
and when we look at that we can see what
the state of the test was at the moment
that it failed and this is slightly
edited the data frame is a lot wider but
we can see the stop station latitude is
zero point zero which probably means a
sensor was wrong or someone messed up
some no handling or something along the
way but this bike trip ends at what Jane
refers to as nowhere island which is
somewhere off the coast of Africa at
zero zero we can also see a little bit
more of the source code to maybe refresh
our memory about what this test was
there's really annoying thing about
Python trace backs though if your
function call spans multiple lines it
only shows you the last line which is
often just like a closed parenthesis so
we did AST tricks to make that work and
then to answer the question why is it
here we added this note field that's
really just like a free-form text field
it'll do like format string stuff so
it's OB easier to work with but you can
write all the contexts that you want in
here
and so here like why is the test here
well it's saying there are some long
trips and what should you do about it
well like if the like go check if these
trips actually happened if someone did
like bike this far I don't know call the
news and say like look how great our
bike share program is or if they're not
let go fix the bikes or fix your your
data ingestion and then to answer how
bad it is you can capture that kind of
in the note you can also kind of use the
local variables to expose some of this
information and we'll get back to like
how to how to choose what you display
and how to write your tests a little bit
differently when you're doing this kind
of thing and so the next so we started
using this and started seeing these
failures come back and found ourselves
looking at that section of source code
pretty frequently and realized we can
actually add more context there so for
that we added what we're calling
semantic assertions which is like
a functionally separate thing but we
package it together with the rest of
marbles and so we noticed that we were
seeing people write things like this
somewhere in their tests and then other
people would write things like this and
evil people would write things like this
so like who can tell me what what each
of these people are trying to to do just
shout it out right so we thought we'd
rather see this and essentially what we
are doing here is capturing like what
did you mean not like how do you check
it so I what I wanted to say is that X
is between the lower and upper
thresholds and so this is like not
rocket science at all but ends up
actually being really powerful so we
have a set of mix-ins
we're sorry I don't need to touch I have
code highlighting we can change the
tests that we've got up here by mixing
in an additional class that adds these
extra assertion methods to your test
case and then you just sort of call them
down there and you can mix in a whole
bunch of different kinds of things these
are the ones we've got so far we would
like to see more some of these actually
are just like straightforward renames so
like a lot of the file mix-ins will be
like we'll actually just call down to a
regular expression of assertion but just
like have a different name which is
useful when you're looking at the test
but so if you have ideas for things like
send us a boat request for an issue so
just to re-emphasize what we've said
like this is absolutely not rocket
science like a lot of these semantic
assertions just call down to a lower
level familiar unit test assertions we
didn't do anything fancy to make them
and you can
definitely write your own if you look at
the marbles mix in source code it should
be pretty obvious to see how you might
start writing your your own assertions
and one reason you might want to do this
is if you want to enforce that sort of
everyone on your team or everyone in
your organization is asserting a sort of
like business requirement in the same
way so in the test case example we've
been using so far we've been asserting
that a subset of a data frame is empty
we've been using the EM tree empty
attribute on the data frame to do this
but someone else at our organization you
know might do it like looking at the
length of the data frame and making sure
that it's zero and so what we can do is
instead to make sure that we're sort of
in sync and we're all doing things in
the same way is we can write a we can
write our customer surgeon and obviously
I'm gonna it's implementation is going
to use the way I did it instead of the
way someone else did it and then what we
can do this is sort of like a silly
example but what we can do is if we ever
need to change you know for whatever
reason for some business reason or
whatever if we need to change the
details about like the implementation
details about how this assertion gets
made everyone using this assertion can
sort of pick up that change we don't
have to go hunt down the people that are
using data frames empty we don't have to
hunt down the people that are looking at
the length of the data frame okay so
we've come we've come pretty far into
our talk you know I was looking for all
of this information I was looking for
all of this context I didn't want to
lose it and like how did we do so again
the first question that I wanted to
answer is like what is this test doing
and why is it here so I'm seeing the
source code I'm seeing the local
variables I'm not looking at like a
traceback and like oh you know I'm
looking at a semantic assertion and I'm
not looking at just like assert true so
I think we get I think we get to check
this one off what am I supposed to do
about this failure so that that
annotation can contain that information
if I'm you know if I'm good if I'm
diligent about writing down that
information in the moment that I'm
writing the test I'm gonna help myself
in the future Oh
sorry thanks how bad is it again the the
local variables sort of show me what are
what was the state of the data at the
time it failed what are the records that
are sort of tripping me up and then the
last question I had was you know have I
seen this failure before and if I have
when have I seen it and that's the thing
you know we haven't quite done that yet
so we added a little bit more and what
we did is essentially we added something
that will log every time you make an
assertion so like every time you call
the assert function it will dump out
some information and you can save that
somewhere and go look at it later and
now it's like a new data set that you
can explore and analyze there's a couple
of ways to turn it on and you can look
at the docs and I think the docs for
this actually need to be improved but
they're okay so you add a little bit of
stuff and you get a sequence of JSON
blobs like this which contain like name
of the test case name of the test method
what was the assertion you made we copy
in the local variables and we have a
kind of odd schema for this which is a
list of Dix with key and value is
because like internally we're using
elasticsearch and it has a wonky data
model but don't worry about it you still
get the same values out and then down
here we can add a little bit of extra
information so when we actually
configured this to generate this example
by configuring the logging to sort of
log month severity and anomaly as as
like separate fields because these are
the things I'm gonna want to look at
later because like this is a time series
data set and there's a couple other
things in here that are not interesting
enough first leg so have we seen this
kind of problem before we can take you
know our months of logs of these
assertions that we've stashed wherever
we've stashed them hope it's not
elasticsearch and we can generate like
plots and so we can say
you know let's say the we got a failure
in September and we want to look at
what's happened in the past well we've
had some kind of 10k rights most of
those maybe were legitimate it looks
like there's sort of an upward trend
recently we're getting into like summer
maybe our bike share program is really
taking off and people are going to the
beach and then we can also see like
something happened in October last year
we got a lot of trips to nowhere island
and like maybe we go back in our emails
and look for did we figure something out
could this be happening again that kind
of thing but also like now your logs are
just another data set that you can
analyze and do whatever you want with so
like you can do aggregations and you can
do reporting and go wild we've done some
things with it like we do sort of
reports and dashboards but you can
imagine doing other things and so like I
mentioned before this this context sort
of preserving all of this context and
preserving all of this information this
isn't unique to data and it's actually
really valuable for software unit tests
too so we're we're getting really really
close to the ends I'm sort of going to
run quickly through the through the rest
of this but this is a this is let's say
I'm working on a code base I'm making a
change and I you know run the test I get
this failure and I'm looking at I'm like
what like what oh okay
I don't read this sighs I don't know
what it's doing we run this under
marbles all of a sudden I can see like
oh I see what this test is doing and I
also see that this is like a really bad
test so when we realized this we
realized that it was gonna be really
really important one of the things that
we wanted from herbals was we wanted
people that had just like software unit
tests to be able to recover all of this
information in all of this context too
so if you have existing unit tests you
can run them under marbles without
changing any of your test code so all
you have to do is pip install marbles
and
and here where you were normal say
normally say Python - mm unitest you can
say Python - M marbles and you'll get
that marbles failure message and now
it's the end of the talk so standard
things
there's github you can go there look at
code send issues we've got pretty good
documentation it's also linked from
there one particular thing about the
documentation it's like partially about
like this is what marbles does and how
to control it but also there's a bunch
in like a section on like how to win it
marbles which is how should you use
these features to write more effective
tests they're like better to receive
failures from so there's like a lot
about like how do you choose which
things you put into local variables
there's like a you can prefix things
with an underscore to hide them if
they're really large that kind of thing
use the issue tracker if you have like
bug reports feature ideas specifically
like ideas for new kinds of mixings if
you notice anything weird with the
documentation or if you just want to ask
questions this is a good place that's it
thank you
it's 5:40 so you're all you should all
go if you want to but we will stick
around and answer questions and as
people are filing out if anyone wants to
raise their hand will answer for
everyone yes so so that's that kind of
like a separate layer so marbles is a is
it's at the layer of like I'm writing
all my tests down and I'm like setting
them up to fail so we can layer things
on top to sort of catch the failures and
for example like maybe have them
automatically create issues in like a
you know some sort of like support tool
that you're using but another thing that
you can do is like if you don't have
like a like a support layer like that
where you can sort of go in and say okay
yes this is fine no that's not fine
whatever you can put that information in
annotation if you're in a little bit of
like a more brass tacks is that a
correct usage of that I don't even know
what that means you can also use that
annotation to say here's where you go to
clear this here's where you go to fail
the entire data set and maybe you can
put anything in that annotation string
it's just a it's just a text field so
you can actually put you can put like
commands to run you can put links like
you can put anything in that annotation
yeah it could be use as kind of a last
gauge before CD like you have production
data coming in I was curious if you had
any ideas about like whether
marbles would have any place in
continuous integration Magana github
github hook on like a pull request build
or anything like that like in that stage
would you still be mocking having test
data stubbing data or would you ever
have a situation where you would use
marbles to validate data before you're
actually in deployment in the
integration stage my question might not
be clear but I think the answer is yes
does this mic work Oh leave him with the
hand home I'm not even so I think yeah
you should definitely do that if you
want I mean the tool is just a test
runner like it's is more friendly but
it's fundamentally like not really any
different so anything that you're using
to run tests in like a CI CD system you
could you could run marbles tests to I
think the question that you're asking is
more on like a like a data sort of
operations strategy question which is
like when in our data set lifecycle do
we need to be asserting these sorts of
things luckily you know marbles it's
like based on unit tests it's like it
should be pretty easy to run it sort of
anywhere in that lifecycle wherever you
decide to put it um I I don't think
there's anything about it that would
prevent you from I'm sort of placing it
at a particular spot okay I just kind of
talked about like you know you would
generally not want to bring in
production data before you really want
so there's some vegetables error test
data and the test one or two finally
using duction data validated
yeah so like one thing specific tomorrow
is that you could do is you could set
your thresholds so that like something
that's not very severe would like be
okay like wouldn't fail your CI system
if it were running on test data but
would fail if you were running on if
you're running like the prod like
a deployment step and like you could
sort of you can tag your tests with like
this is critical this is not that kind
of thing and like differentiate their
otherwise they I think it's like an
organizational strategy question yeah I
think we had yeah apply you wanted that
question it looks like you're supporting
only unit tests today have you looked at
the other PI test functional test dot
test formats
what are those anything you're looking
at supporting we've definitely looked at
all of them a lot so there's a section
in the docs
explaining the difference between sort
of marbles and PI tests like my initial
response was yeah I think you can use PI
test to do that but then like when we
really dug into the problem we realize
that it's like it's solving a different
problem and of the other test runners
like doc test is testing about
documentation no actually I want to use
marbles on my PI test functional test
right that's the other side of the I see
the value so that that's cool
we've looked at that and it just it's
really it's really hard like the way
that we make this work is hooking into
some internal stuff in unit tests and
like redoing that in PI test would be I
don't know how you would do that the
other thing about PI test is like its
style is to encourage you to use the
assert keyword and it's kind of unclear
where you would put a note in if like if
the note thing is what you're looking
for it's unclear where you would put
that in inside like the test body and
like some of the other things that
marbles does like showing you local
variables PI test Blake does something
similar to I think there's a flag you
set but so like some of that is already
kind of captured yeah
I I do have to give closing remarks I
believe I'll stay and hang out if maybe
leaf will stay and hang out
thank you all for Jill for coming along
giving round of applause for Jane and
leave
[Applause]